police are investigating a deadly  stabbing in the east valley it happened  in a parking lot around 4 this morning  on pecos near craig road police say a  man in his 20's was found with stab  wounds and taken to the local hospital  where he died the person who brought him  there was able to bring north las vegas  police to the crime scene metro's  homicide unit was called in shortly  after as it happened in their  jurisdiction  through their investigation they  the vehicle that dropped them off we  were able to speak to some individuals  that led him to that location  the suspect is still on the run however  police say they believe it's an isolated  incident and the public is not at risk  anyone with information is asked to call  crime stoppers at the number on your  screen